welcome back to new rockstars I'm your
host Sam basher and this is the third
installment in the MCU rewatch breakdown
series so I've covered the first Ironman
film and Edward Norton's Incredible Hulk
film which you can go check out on this
channel but now let's talk about the
official third installment of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Iron Man 2 today I'll
be going over every single Easter egg
hidden reference to a comic book or
another movie basically every secret I
could possibly find about this movie
here's your spoiler warning for Iron Man
one two three and all other MCU
properties that being movies TV shows
comic books let's kick it off as usual
with connections what little Easter eggs
the director Jon Favreau leave for us in
this film starting with the intro to the
film we meet our antagonist and his
deadbeat Ivan and Anton Vanko
respectively oh boy I'm already excited
you see our main antagonist Ivan Vanko
actually doesn't exist in the comics or
at least at the time this movie was made
there was an Anton Vanko and a whiplash
but no Ivan Ivan was an original
character for this movie but no one
really freaked out over it so it's all
good now let's break this down
the first official whiplash appearance
was in Marvel team-up number 145 in 1984
this character was marked scholar Otte
and originally went by backlash then
fast forward through a few different
people taking up the mantle of backlash
or whiplash whatever eventually we got
in 2010
Anton Vanko whiplash which was trying to
line up with the movie but they still
didn't call him Ivan for some reason
here comes the fun part the name
Anton Vanko actually belongs to two
characters now and the original one was
this retro Iron Man villain named
Crimson Dynamo
he's clearly a Russian villain get a
crimson red communism there you go you
don't really think too hard with this
one now while the Crimson Dynamo doesn't
exactly appear in this film a version of
the Crimson Dynamo does appear in the
Iron Man 2 video game but I do like the
creative choice of having this villain
family existing in the MCU then scooting
forward to the stark Expo wouldn't mind
going there myself it looked really cool
we get a glimpse of Olivia Munn as chess
Roberts chess Roberts playing a very
small part in both the movie and in the
comics specifically in the heroes return
iron man storyline from 1998 moving
forward to the Senate hearing we're
introduced to Sam Rockwell's character
Justin Hammer
just to plug a fellow Sam for a minute
you should all go stop what you're doing
right now and watch moon we'll finish
this video then go
watch moon Sam Rockwell's amazing in
that movie anywho Justin Hammer appeared
in Iron Man number 120 in 1979 well not
really having powers in the comics he
was still a genius and he had a vast
amount of resources at his disposal in
the movie they kind of domed him down a
little bit made him a little awkward but
I just I'm gonna be honest I just love
this Justin Hammer also the just that
the spray tan they have all over his
hands it looks so bad but I love it I
also just want to point out the Justin
Hammer giving venko you know resources
getting me out of jail that seems pretty
similar to his comic book counterpart
also fun fact originally the team behind
Iron Man 2 wanted an older version of
Justin Hammer that was true or to the
comics and they wanted the main actor to
play the role to be Al Pacino which
would have been interesting let's save
him for another character yeah let me
know who you want Al Pacino to play in
the comments down below
ego too he'll play ego again also during
the scene Tony mentions being the
secretary of defense and a joiner but
I'll consider Secretary of Defense of
last night which was a fun nod to when
he actually was appointed to Secretary
of Defense for a brief time in the
comics moving forward - I even getting a
fake passport from a mysterious man
check out the name on that fake passport
Boris Turgenev try my best with that one
this is actually the second person to
take up the identity of Crimson Dynamo
in the comics yay legacy throwbacks s1
next up we see tony handing over the
company to pepper so that she can become
CEO which is something that actually
happens quite a bit in the comics Tony
really does not like to run his own
company next we see happy and tony
training in the ring that being a
throwback to happy in the comics having
a history with boxing pretty fun this is
also the scene where we're first
introduced to Black Widow fun fact like
Widow made her debut as an antagonist to
Ironman in tales of suspense number 52
in 1964 also Natalie rushman her alias
in this film is a throwback to one of
her aliases from the comics nancy
rushman then moving on to Monaco and the
race that goes on it's pretty cool you
can see a Roxxon logo sponsoring one of
the Formula one cars this is one of the
you know evil companies in the MCU
actually saw it in the first Ironman as
well fun throwback again this is also
the scene where we see the suitcase
deployed Iron Man suit which is always
going to be awesome just a little clip
really quick
[Music]
I love that then fast word of tony's
bday party we see tony getting
dangerously intoxicated because of his
failure at the racetrack and then
talking to Vanko and in the poison in
his blood but i think there's something
more here in the comics tony has had
some pretty serious stories revolving
around his alcoholism and while this is
still a family film i think jon favreau
and the writers wanted to incorporate
some of those aspects of those stories
in this movie maybe i mean I'm always
game for Marvel kind of tackling more
adult subjects but you can only do so
much in this amount of time and Marvel
just shoving so many storylines into one
movie then we get the fight between Iron
Man and the Iron Man suit mark - aka war
machine it's pretty cool Rhodey he wears
it well also this is the scene where you
actually get the name war machine check
it out
you want to be the war machine take your
shot put it down when can we get the
audience get it then we got a pretty fun
comic book throwback literally because
if you pay attention to this crate that
Tony is sifting through in this scene
there's a copy of Captain America number
one hiding underneath those papers yay
then we get a fun cameo back at these
stark offices pay attention to our
friend the secretary right here this
character would be Bambi Arbogast
laplace of that right she made her first
appearance in invincible Iron Man number
118 in 1979 and remember that issue
because that's also the debut of our
best friend war machine who we got a
pretty comic accurate first debut with
his full suit at the expo I'm a big fan
of that suit by the way
well that's scooching back for a second
because there's something weird that
happens when stark makes that new
element with that atom smasher in his
workshop
it actually isn't that new at least it
shouldn't be to him or the rest of the
Marvel Universe in the novelization of
Iron Man 2 they actually give this
element a name and they refer to it as
vibranium we played around with that
material enough times to know that this
isn't new at all held Tony's dad used it
to make Captain America's shield and
black panthers have been playing with it
forever now what I actually think it is
my guess is that if you take a look at
the sketch in one of the notebooks that
Tony's flipping through we see a four
dimensional tesseract which could be
Howard you know studying the tesseract
in from the first Captain America movie
my fan theory is that what if he came up
with a way to manufacture some of the
energy within the tesseract possibly and
maybe Tony somehow taps into that making
this new little triangle dance qg4 we
see warmest changes wanted to show it
one more time because he looks so
and then during all the commotion we
actually see Black Widow using some of
our fighting skills and her risk tasers
from the comics as a very cool scene I'm
a big fan of it love the curls but after
the big fight we get a fun tease for the
Avengers but that's not the most
exciting thing in this scene is also
something playing on one of those
screens I'll get to that in a second
what I want to pay attention to right
now is the map in the background of this
shield base look at all those icons I'm
thinking that these are subtle teases to
some of the locations of maybe Infinity
stones or locations of possible Avengers
but maybe there's something else here I
know there's a bunch of fan theories
about this but I want to go a little bit
more in depth let's pay attention to the
two that we can see most clearly the
first marker is over Africa which I
think we're all on the same page here
that this is probably a nod to Wakanda
mean that shield might be keeping an eye
on black panther or maybe they know more
about what Condor than the rest of the
world the second dot is even more
intriguing though I'm feeling like this
is a marker for none other than name or
aka the Submariner now why would it be
in the middle of the ocean you've been
asking me in the comments down below
well I could answer that really easily
he's the king of Atlantis yes there is
an Atlantis in the comics they also call
it a few different names but I cannot
pronounce them very well so we'll call
it Atlantis now I wouldn't mind seeing
some version of Atlantis in the MCU but
it would definitely confuse audiences
with the new Aquaman movie coming out
now that's it for comic book tie-ins now
I want to talk about MCU Easter eggs oh
everybody's favorite fun fact there was
actually an alternate intro to Iron Man
2 that kind of alluded to Tony's
alcoholism a little bit that's what I
got from it also when you watch the full
scene which I recommend you doing it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
leading into the rest of the movie at
least to me I don't know about you guys
let me know what you thought of it in
the comments down below also worth
pointing out that the stark Expo in this
movie is not the very first stark Expo
no no we actually get hints of that with
Howard Stark Tony's dad but also we see
one of the very first dark Expos in
Captain America the First Avenger but
I'm getting ahead of myself next I want
to give a shout out to WH IH the
fictional news network that we've seen
in multiple MCU properties actually
Olivia Munn is our reporter for this
network very fun next I want to skip
ahead just for a second remember when
Tom Holland said that oh there's a fun
little Easter egg maybe Peter Parker is
actually in Iron Man 2 is a small little
boy in the helmet that almost dies well
fun fact that little boy you
Parker actually shows up in the very
beginning when Tony's walking through
the expo check him out right there very
cool
next up scoot into the Senate hearing we
have senator Stern who actually makes a
second appearance in Captain America
Winter Soldier whose spoiler alert is a
member of Hydra then I want to mention
Justin Hammer one more time because this
is not the only Marvel property that
this name pops up and he is in that
little short that we see with Ben
Kingsley and a hint to the other
Mandarin that might be out there but
also hammer tech is used in the first
season of Luke Cage I highly recommend
checking out that show I really like the
first half of it also it's worth
mentioning that this is the first
official appearance of Don Cheadle as
James Rhodes aka war machine in the MCU
right here in this Senate hearing next
up in Monaco we see Christine Everhart
again she was a reporter in iron man one
who kind of outs Tony just a little bit
she works for Vogue and she's doing a
piece on Justin Hammer so I'm guessing
from here until ant-man at some point
she eventually gets hired by whi H no
idea when though man scooching Ford a
bunch to the Air Force Base that you
know Rhodey drops off the war machine
armor too we see major Allen who's
actually a character that popped up in
Iron Man 1 and he doesn't have a huge
role but I do like the Jon Favreau
brought him over yeah it's good to see
you hopefully you're healthy and happy
then we get the first full look at Nick
Fury acting like Nick Fury and not just
saying six lines in the dark and Tony
Stark's house we do get a very fun tease
the Nick Fury and Howard Stark have
worked together in the past teamwork I
would actually like to see those two
actors play together in a scene together
I know that'd be kind of hard but the
Captain Marvel movie is supposed to take
place in the past so possibly we could
see a hint of brie Larson's Captain
Marvel Howard Stark and Nick Fury all on
a scene together maybe who knows I'm up
for it speaking of shield though we do
see Phil Coulson again in the MCU it's
always good to see you you look healthy
next up we see Tony looking through a
couple notes and trinkets that Howard
left form we see a map of Antarctica now
I think this could actually be a tease
too Howard looking for Captain America
frozen somewhere at least to find his
body to bury or here comes fun comic
book nerd theory maybe he knows about
the Savage Land
what's the Savage Land yes Sam oh it's
just a place where dinosaurs live in
Antarctica I don't like that theory now
I'm sorry I feel like I heard dinosaurs
aside we do get a very fun tease to the
test right
here in Howard's notes but also we see
the Captain America Easter egg from Iron
Man 1 pay off with Phil Coulson bringing
out the prototype of Captain America
shield yay and I used it for trash what
kind of message do you think Jon Favreau
was sending the fans with this ain't
coming back again Coulson mentions that
he's going to the southwest why well in
the post-credits scene we find out that
he's found the location of mew mew or
meal near I'm glad that joke is over
since Ragnarok and lastly for MCU Easter
eggs check out this shot right here in
the shield base but that screen up there
oh good happy oh that would just be the
cell phone footage that those two
ding-dongs took in the Incredible Hulk
film remember those guys there's a big
war going on and two just dumb college
students take out their cell phones and
film it well that would be the same
footage very exciting so that means that
these are happening around the same time
these two movies and lastly here are the
pop-culture references for Iron Man 2
because there are quite a few first up
Iron Man 2 there's actually a version of
the shoot - thrills ac/dc song there's a
version of that music video that
incorporates Iron Man 2 that they use
the stage of the stark Expo to be like
the concert stage it's super weird and I
recommend you checking in it but it's
worth mentioning anyways moving forward
to the stark Expo Jon Favreau mentioned
that he actually looked to Apple
keynotes as a way to like you know
emulate them and get that kind of feel
when Tony Stark appears on stage if Tim
Cook appeared in an Iron Man suit Nick's
I just want to mention that Olivia Munn
showed up in the MCU and then she went
on to play psylocke in x-men apocalypse
also when Tony's making his way through
the expo in the very beginning of the
movie he passes Larry Ellison even gives
him a shout-out who is the co-founder of
Oracle and also you guys remember Oracle
is that little glass sphere that where
they have that last fight with more
machine versus the drones versus Iron
Man vs. whiplash was Japanese flowers of
fall it's very cool it's very pretty
next we get Elon Musk himself in Monaco
yes that's him and Tony actually talking
and fun fact when hammer and whiplash
are having their meeting in that hangar
that is actually a space ex hangar hmm
I'm always a fan of SpaceX then moving
forward to the suitcase Iron Man suit
you again I love that so much they
nicknamed it the football which is
actually a fun nod to the suitcase that
you know contains the nuclear codes that
the president carries around now this
cameo that I'm about to mention is a
little sadder DJ am the guy who is DJing
Tony Stark's birthday he was a very
popular DJ but sadly he passed before
this movie was
and this movie ended up being dedicated
to him but moving forward stark expose
model the one that Tony uses to find
this new mysterious element it was
actually based on the New York World's
Fair from 1964 to 1965 and I boy I wish
I could have gone to that that would
have been amazing and here's a fun
Easter Egg when hammer is dancing on
stage to do his performance about war
machine all of his drones he's doing it
to the song pick up the pieces by
average white band which was prominently
used in swingers a film that jon favreau
made it's really nerdy and really cheesy
but I'm always a fan of that and lastly
boys and girls the Stan Lee cameo he's
right there dressed as Larry King
referred to as Larry King and he doesn't
really say anything either so huh and
then they cut away and that's it for my
video boys and girls I hope you enjoyed
let me know which one of these was your
favor and if I missed anything please
let me know in the comments or on
Twitter at Sam bash or make sure you
like this video though before you do
anything make sure you subscribe to new
boxers for more content check out my
panel show with Eric Voss Maude Garrett
and fimo every week and I'll see you
next time